sur le texte y a-t-il des observations
je n'en vois pas elle en est ainsi
décidé
alors l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen
des crédits de la mission santé et
l'article 46 bis du projet de loi de
finance pour 2023 et la parole est à
Monsieur Christian Klinger rapporteur
spécial de la commission des finances
pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues année après année
notre Assemblée a émis des doutes sur la
pertinence de cette mission santé
déséquilibrée entre l'aide médicale
d'État dont la maîtrise budgétaire n'est
toujours pas assurée et un programme
prévention sécurité sanitaire peu à peu
vider de toute substances se résument à
des actions hétérogènes et résiduelles
de santé publique
un élément nouveau intervient cette
année avec la création du programme
recevant les crédits européens de
soutien à l'investissement en santé soit
6 milliards d'euros d'ici 2026 le suivi
budgétaire de ces fonds
pour autant d'impact à la mission
en termes de politique publique beaucoup
d'actions financées par la mission ont
été transférées à l'assurance maladie au
fil des années toutefois pour les
besoins de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire l'état il y a rapatrié depuis
trois ans dans un fonds de concours près
d'un milliard de crédit venant de santé
publique France
ces sommes n'ont jamais fait l'objet
d'approbation parlementaire que ce soit
en loi de finance initiale ou en
collectif budgétaire il est souhaitable
de mettre ses fonds de concours en
extinction et de clarifier et stabiliser
la répartition des missions entre l'État
et santé publique France en matière de
veille sanitaire et de préparation aux
crises le programme 204 connaît peu
d'évolution je relève toutefois une
diminution de la dotation versée à
l'ONIAM tenant compte de la
sous-consommation des crédits
d'undemnisation des victimes de la
dépakine j'ai souligné dans le contrôle
budgétaire effectué sur ce sujet un non
recours significatif à ce jour il
pourrait néanmoins s'atténuer en dotant
l’oniam des moyens nécessaires pour
diminuer les délais et résorber les
retards dans le traitement des dossiers
la mission intègre les premiers effets
budgétaires du transfert à l'ancêtre de
compétences aujourd'hui d'évoluent à
l'agence de sécurité du médicament en
matière de cosmétique et de produits de
tatouages
cette réforme repose sur des constats
détaillés de longue date il est donc
discutable qu'elle intervienne sous
forme d'amendement déposé tardivement
dans le PLF
l'aide médicale d'État demeure l'élément
principal de la mission santé le
gouvernement propose pour 2023 une
majoration de 133 millions pour la me de
droit commun
les crédits atteindraient un milliard
141 millions soit une hausse de 13,2%
par rapport à la loi de finances
initiale 2022 la commission des finances
a jugé cette augmentation étonnante et
contestable à plus d'un titre d'abord
elles se fondent sur une prolongation
pure et simple de l'évolution
tendancielle observée avant la crise
sanitaire c'est-à-dire que le
gouvernement table sur une poursuite de
la progression du nombre d'étrangers en
situation irrégulière au moment même où
il prépare son projet de loi précisément
destiné à le réduire c'est une
contradiction difficilement justifiable
deuxièmement le gouvernement nous a
présenté il y a trois ans des mesures de
contrôle et de lutte contre la fraude
ils n'ont résulte aucune inflexion du
rythme d'évolution des dépenses doit-on
en déduire que ces mesures sont
inefficaces dans ce cas c'est qu'elles
sont insuffisantes et qu'il faut les
renforcer mais rien n'est proposé dans
ce sens
troisièmement le PLF adopté il y a
quelques jours établi la prévision de
dépenses d'ame de droit commun à 944
millions en 2022 c'est donc en réalité
une augmentation de près de 200 millions
et de plus de 20% qui est proposé alors
même que l'État dispose désormais d'une
créance sur l'assurance maladie qui
pourrait atteindre 45 millions fin 2022
face à ce pilotage déficient et cette
charge budgétaire non maîtrisée la
commission des finances propose de
nouveau de revoir l'étendue des soins
prise en charge par la hame et de
réduire les crédits pour 2023
par l'éventail des soins couverts la me
constitue par rapport au pays voisins
une exception difficile à justifier dans
la plupart d'entre eux seuls les soins
urgents les soins liés à la maternité
les soins aux mineurs et les dispositifs
de soins préventives dans les programmes
sanitaires publics sont prises en charge
gratuitement pour les étrangers en
situation irrégulière
c'est ce que le Sénat avait adopté il y
a deux ans sur notre proposition et
celle de la commission des affaires
sociales la commission des finances
propose donc l'adoption des crédits de
la mission assortie de ces amendements
merci beaucoup chers collègues la parole
est à Madame Annie Delmont coropolis
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires sociales pour 3 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente Madame la midi ce
sera mes chers
que la commission des affaires sociales
déplore le caractère à la fois
hétéroclite chétif sur le plan financier
et en définitive inadapté aux enjeux
sanitaires de la mission santé du PLF
en 2023 les crédits de la mission
progresseront de 159%, mais cette hausse
ne s'explique que par la création d'un
nouveau programme doté de 1,93 milliards
d'euros et servant de simples canal
budgétaires adoc pour faire transiter
jusqu'en 2026 le soutien européen aux
dépenses d'investissement Ségur la
politique sanitaire n'y gagne après a
priori pas grand chose car pour le reste
les changements sont minces les crédits
de prévention sanitaires du programme
204 augmente peu et le programme
contribue de manière toujours aussi
résiduelle et hétérogène au financement
des agences de santé et de la politique
de prévention difficile dans ces
conditions d'évaluer sa contribution aux
objectifs qu'il se fixent et au moyen
d'indicateurs aussi disparate que ce
qu'il retient
quant au crédit consacré aux actions
contentieuses il diminue de 11 millions
d'euros ce qui dit simplement l'ampleur
du non recours au mécanisme
d'indemnisation des victimes de la
dépakine ou l'incapacité à chiffrer
l'impact financier de l'indemnisation
des victimes de la campagne du
vaccination contre le covid-19
appuyons-nous pour mieux anticiper sur
les rapports rendus sur ce chapitre par
nos collègues de la commission des
finances et de l'OPEX l'essentiel de la
hausse des crédits de la mission à
périmètre constant s'explique par celle
des dépenses de l'aide médicale de
l'état qui atteindront 1,14 milliards
d'euros en 2023 par le retour à la
dynamique de dépenses antérieure à la
crise sanitaire c'est pourquoi nos
collègues de la mission des finances
sont adoptés cette année encore
l'amendement du rapporteur spécial
Christian Klinger qui recentre l'ame
rebaptisée aide médicale de santé
publique sur un noyau des dépenses
d'urgence et alignent ainsi son
périmètre sur celui du dispositif
équivalent en Allemagne la commission
des affaires sociales y a vu elle aussi
un bon moyen de recentrer le dispositif
sur son objectif humanitaire et
sanitaire elle propose seulement de le
comp par la création d'un programme de
soutien aux personnes en situation
irrégulière afin de leur proposer des
examens de prévention et de dépistage je
le vois en Seine-Saint-Denis en tant que
parlementaire mais aussi depuis des
décennies en tant que médecin et les
élus d'Aubervilliers qui sont en tribune
en témoigneraient également les
bénéficiaires potentiels de l'AM son par
hypothèse en situation précaire leur
état de santé est fragile ils sont en
outre la proie des dealers il faut les
protéger activement de ce fléau dans
l'intérêt de tout merci
merci chocolat dans la suite de notre
discussion je vous rappelle que le temps
de parole attribue à chaque groupe pour
chaque unité de discussion comprend le
temps d'intervention générale et celui
de l'explication de vote par ailleurs le
gouvernement dispose au total de 10
minutes pour intervenir la parole est à
Monsieur Daniel Chassin pour le groupe
les indépendants pour 4 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame le rapporteur monsieur le
rapporteur de la commission des finances
mes chers collègues la crise sanitaire
que nous traversons a mis sous une
lumière crue toute l'importance du
secteur sanitaire nous manquons
d'infirmières d'aide soignante qu'il
faut former massivement avec des IPA la
suppression du numérique clausus et la
quatrième année ne vont pas permettre
d'augmenter le nombre de médecins avant
plusieurs années la mission de santé
examiner aujourd'hui concerne trois
programmes le 379 avec 1,9 milliards
d'euros concerne simplement en canal
budgétaire pour la compensation de la
sécurité sociale par des crédits
européens pour des investissements en
santé
le but en fait la mission c'est deux
programmes le 204 avec 313 millions
d'euros augmente de 1,6% pour la
prévention sanitaire de maladie
chronique environnementale nutrition
indemnisation amiable lutte contre le
tabac indemnisation
des modernisations des offres de soins
évaluation sur le dépistage
colorectal etc
mais c'est surtout le programme 183
consacré à l'aide médicale de l'état ce
dispositif est destiné à financer les
lois des immigrés des soins des immigrés
en situation
irrégulières il nous honore en 2023 les
crédits qui sont alloués progressent de
13%, c'est 1,14 milliards d'euros que
nous concitoyens vont consacrer à
soigner des personnes en situation
irrégulière sur le territoire français
le périmètre des soins remboursés plus
larges actuellement doit revenir sur ce
qui se fait dans les pays voisins
pendant les trois premiers mois nous
devons recentrer les admissions sur les
traitements et le madigraphe et des
soins d'urgence et profilaxie des
maladies graves les grossesses c'est de
dispositif humanitaire pratiquant en
Allemagne et dans les pays voisins
d'autre part certains patients
proviennent parfois des pays du G20
n'habitent pas en France depuis trois
mois n'ont pas de pathologie d'une
extrême d'une exceptionnelle gravité est
souvent
dans le traitement pour être réalisé
dans leur pays ces prises en charge se
font dans le cadre d'une procédure
d'admission au titre de séjour pour soin
dans le défaut pourrait avoir des
conséquences d'une exceptionnelle
gravité et se disposent dispositif et la
logements largement contourné nous
devons aussi contrôler les fraudes à
l'identité aux ressources et la
résidence je soutiens l'amendement de
madame le rapporteur concernant
l'attribution de crédit dans des actions
mobiles de prévention pour les personnes
qui en ont besoin dans le cadre de
marottes notamment l'augmentation du
nombre de bénéficiaires de 350 60 35000
en 2020 ils sont de 400 000 environ en
2022 les mesures de 2019 comparution
physique pour la demande en cap
d'aider d'ancienneté ont été supprimés
pendant le covid il faudra y associer à
mon avis les maisons de France service
quand les CPAM sont parfois éloignés des
populations
l'investissement de long terme en
matière de santé de santé doit rester
notre priorité en ce qui concerne
l'humanisme nous devons rester comme
l'indique madame le rapporteur a des
notions d'urgence pendant les trois
premiers mois le groupe des indépendants
votera donc en faveur de son adoption
merci
merci beaucoup la parole est à Madame
Raymonde pense et Monge pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire pour 4
minutes chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues l'OMF définit la santé
comme un état de complet bien-être
physique mental et sociale qui ne
consiste pas seulement une absence de
maladie ou d'infirmité les mesures
contenues dans ce projet de loi de
finance dans la continuité du PLFSS
montre que nous n'empruntons pas
totalement le chemin de cet objectif sur
le bien-être physique en France à
l'heure du risque d'effondrement de
l'hôpital et des zones soudées en oeuvre
médicale une part importante de français
renonce à des soins médicaux les
maladies chroniques progressent les
indicateurs de périnatalité restent
préoccupants la santé mentale est en
berne et dans ce contexte les crédits de
la mission santé augmentent de seulement
4,2%, je renvoie à l'inflation en effet
l'augmentation de 159% des crédits est
lié à l'intégration du programme 379 qui
reverse des crédits européens à mesure
que les délais d'attentes pour obtenir
des rendez-vous s'allonge avec ces
pertes de chances les délais pour que
vous preniez les réelles mesures
structurelles pour s'attaquer au
déterminants sociaux et géographique des
inégalités de santé s'avèrent tout aussi
long en effet s'agissant du bien-être
social les fractures sociales et
territoriales sont criantes fractures
reflétées dans les finances le budget de
l'action santé des populations dont
l'objet de corriger les inégalités de
garantir pour tous les meilleures
chances face à la maladie stagne
représentant 0,6% du programme programme
prévention sécurité sanitaire et offre
de soins lui-même sous de thé selon
l'adresse pourtant de la naissance au
grand âge les problèmes de santé
évoluent mais les inégalités demeurent à
titre d'exemple à part de personnes
souffrant d'obésité diminue lorsque le
niveau de vie ou de diplôme augmente et
les femmes résidents dans les drones
présent risque de mortalité maternelle
multipliée par 4 par rapport à celle
vivant en hexagone quand au bien-être
mental je renvoie aux manifestations
d'aujourd'hui la santé mentale est au
PLF ce que la psychiatrie est à la
médecine c'est-à-dire le parent pauvre
des crédits de la mission santé
tandis que le coût annuel direct et
indirect des troubles psychiques estimés
à 109 milliards d'euros le PLF réserve à
la santé mentale une sous-action dotée
d'un million d'euros environ soit une
part infime des crédits de la mission
nous demandons au gouvernement de lancer
enfin un plan d'urgence pour la
psychiatrie enfin quant au budget de la
m.e
vient-il peut-être de rappeler qu'il ne
représente que
0,5% des dépenses de la substrance
maladie et je vous demande cette
focalisation de quoi est-elle le nom
nous défendons nous à l'inverse dans une
logique de solidarité et aussi de santé
publique le retour aux conditions
d'attribution de 2020 soit la fin du
délai de résidence de trois mois
les moyens d'évoluent à la mission santé
reste insuffisamment ambitieux et
notamment ceux des volu à la santé
globale à la prévention et surtout à la
réduction des déterminants sociaux et
territoriaux les inégalités de santé
c'est pourquoi le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire votera contre
le budget de cette mission je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Monsieur
Xavier yakovelli pour le groupe
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants pour 4
minutes
pas plus je vous promets pas plus
madame la présidente madame Lamiche
chers collègues la mission santé traduit
les engagements de l'État à développer
la politique de prévention assurer la
sécurité sanitaire et organiser une
offre de soins de qualité à adapter à
toutes et à tous sur les territoires
au-delà de la ligne budgétaire au-delà
des chiffres et pars la mission comporte
en son cœur une politique de solidarité
qui nous est propre l'aide médicale
d'État pour rappel près de 300 000
personnes bénéficier de l'ame de droit
commun en offrant également à ses
bénéficiaires un accès aux soins de
ville la me permet la prise en charge en
amont des pathologies et évite ainsi les
surcoûts liés à des soins retardés et
pratiqués dans l'urgence
je souhaite souligner mes chers
collègues quand 2019 et 2020
parallèlement aux actions menées en
matière de lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière le gouvernement a mis en
place des mesures pour réguler les
dépenses et renforcer les contrôles dans
le cadre du programme ciblé si toutefois
le périmètre de cette mission est assez
limité elle comprend trois programmes
qui actent la solidarité de l'État et ça
politique en matière de prévention les
exercices 2020 2021 et 2022 ont été
fortement marqués par la gestion de la
crise de la covid-19 mais 2023 devrait
constituer une année charnière notamment
au regard des événements sportifs
attendus fin 2023 qui justifie des
réflexions pour anticiper des mesures de
prévention à mettre en oeuvre les
crédits de cette mission devrait donc
continuer à être mobilisé au moins
jusqu'au 1er semestre 2023 sur la
gestion de la crise sanitaire et de ses
impacts
les crédits de la mission s'élèvent donc
à 3,36 milliards soit une hausse de 2
milliards par rapport à 2022 une hausse
due à l'ajout des crédits dans le cadre
du plan national de relance de
résilience il permettra à l'état de
reverser à la sécurité sociale les
crédits européens perçus dans le cadre
du plan de au titre du financement des
dépenses d'investissement dans les
établissements de santé médico-sociaux
une hausse conséquence des crédits est
également visible concernant la sécurité
sanitaire plus 124% par rapport à 2022
ces crédits permettront de poursuivre
des objectifs en matière de veille de
prévention des risques ou encore de
gestion des crises cette mission santé
tire donc en quelque sorte les leçons de
la crise sanitaire et nous donnera donc
les moyens adéquats pour préparer
l'avenir d'autre part cette mission mais
également en avant la santé de la mer et
de l'enfant via le financement du profit
d'associations jouent un rôle dans le
domaine périnatal
c'est crédit viseront également à
améliorer la prévention des troubles
sensoriels et apprentis et des
apprentissages mais aussi d'améliorer et
de promouvoir la qualité de l'accueil
des enfants malades en milieu intra et
extra hospitalier en France plus d'un
virgule un million de personnes sont
atteintes de maladies d'Alzheimer ou de
maladie apparentées selon les dernières
estimations de l'Agence nationale de la
santé publique et il existe plus de 2
millions de dents soit au total plus de
3 millions de personnes concernées dans
ce contexte la prévention des maladies
chroniques et la qualité de vie des
malades représentent 24% des crédits
alloués et vise notamment au financement
de l'Institut national du cancer pour
40,5 millions de la prévention des
addictions des maladies neuro
dégénératives et des maladies liées au
vieillissement c'est un axe majeur pour
prévenir le plus tôt possible les
complications de santé tout au long de
la vie cette action comprend également
des crédits dédiés à la santé mentale un
million d'euros afin de soutenir les
acteurs associatifs celle-ci doit être
intensifiée compte tenu de l'altération
de la santé mentale de la population
suite à la crise de la covid et
notamment chez les jeunes il en va de
l'avenir de nos jeunesse de notre
jeunesse dans la continuité du PLFSS
cette mission donc suit la ligne de la
prévention de la solidarité et du
soutien des politiques publiques aux
associations qui œuvrent chaque jour au
côté de ceux qui sont en difficulté et
pour toutes ces raisons le groupe RDPI
votera cette mission
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Bernard jaumier pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
pour 6 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mais ce rapporteur mes chers collègues
nos étudiants maintenant la mission
santé du PLF qui est une mission au
périmètre limité nous allons dire et
nous sommes pour notre parcours qu'elle
doit être conservée avec le périmètre de
l'action de l'État en la matière de doit
d'ailleurs être repensée dans ses
missions dans ses moyens tant dans le
domaine financier qu'en termes de
gouvernance et de prévention s'il n'y a
plus grand chose dans cette mission
c'est parce que l'État délègue toujours
davantage la politique de santé à
l'assurance maladie c'est le cas
notamment des transferts financiers
c'est le cas de la dette covid par
exemple qui est en intégralité
maintenant porter par les crédits de
l'assurance maladie
ne nous égarons donc pas ce budget qui
est en augmentation de deux fois et demi
de montant de l'année précédente et du à
l'intégration du programme 379 qui
permet à l'état de reverser à la
sécurité sociale les crédits européens
perçus dans le cadre du plan de relance
cela n'a donc aucune influence sur les
politiques publiques portées dans le
cadre de la mission la mission 204 elle
prévention sécurité sanitaire et offre
de soins est en augmentation par rapport
à 2022 depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire elle sert de support indirect
à la gestion de crise avec par exemple
l'achat de matériel ou de systèmes
d'information
la commission d'enquête sur l'influence
croissante des cabinets de conseils
privés sur les politiques publiques du
Sénat à pairailleurs relevé que cette
mission consacrée des montants
importants au paiement des cabinets de
conseil cette augmentation budgétaire
n'apporte donc en ce début de
quinquennat pas de nouvelles
dispositions importantes par ailleurs
nous sommes particulièrement déçus de
l'absence totale de politique de
prévention dans ce budget de l'État le
texte ne comporte que peu de programmes
spécifiques et pas de hausse que de
crédit significative en faveur d'un
programme de prévention et nous en
sommes d'autant plus déçus qu'avant la
publication du texte sur le PLFSS nous
avions quelques espoirs en la matière
les propos du ministre de la Santé de
porter un virage de la prévention avait
recueilli recueille toujours notre
soutien et nous aurions accueilli avec
bienveillance toutes les mesures fortes
en la matière
mais c'était sans compter sur
l'arbitrage politique du ministre des
contes publics qui s'inscrit dans la
lignée habituelle et non exceptionnelle
des ministres portant une politique de
contrainte sur le système de soins
alors que la crise covid est passée par
là nous pourrions dresser une longue
liste des sujets manquants en matière de
prévention mais nous nous limiterons à
la santé environnementale qui depuis
2016 a inscrit dans la loi a fait
l'objet de nombreux travaux
et nous ne voyons toujours aucune
disposition du gouvernement en la
matière comme il n'y a d'ailleurs
quasiment rien sur la psychiatrie et la
santé mentale
par ailleurs
concernant les agences sanitaires nous
regrettons toujours que l'Agence
nationale de santé publique soit
financée par la Sécurité sociale depuis
son transfert au sphère opéré dans la
loi de finance de la sécurité sociale en
2020 les missions de sécurité sanitaire
et de gestion de crise d'évoluer cette
agence nous le rappelons sont des
missions régaliennes qui exigent un
retour dans le budget de l'État par
ailleurs fallait-il créer fin octobre
une énième agence une nouvelle agence
celle de l'innovation en santé pour
accélérer la mise sur le marché des
innovations françaises
il existait une mission
ministérielle avec deux personnes deux
équivalent temps plein mais ces
personnes n'ont déjà ayant pas été
transférés à l'agence allons-nous
maintenir et accroître le mille-feuille
en la matière cet agence c'est un pur
produit d'un système de gouvernement qui
n'est pas efficient parce qu'il
multiplie les agences en organisant la
confusion des rôles et des missions
j'en viens au programme 183 ln medicale
d'État tous les ans et nous le
regrettons c'est un sujet qui est
l'objet de posture et nous en débattrons
lors de l'examen des amendements cette
année les crédits sont portés à 1,14
milliards d'euros je vous invite mes
chers collègues à vous pencher sur les
raisons de cette augmentation qui réside
pour une large part dans la hausse du
recours à l'hôpital et par ailleurs
quand on regarde le nombre de
délivrances de titres de séjour ça
diminuation drastique dans notre pays de
facto et immédiatement entraîne un
accroissement des noms de personnes qui
relèvent de la me et non pas des
dispositifs de l'assurance maladie c'est
les mesures restrictives en la matière
sont à contre-courant l'installation
l'instauration d'un délai de carence de
trois mois pour la c'est à la Puma des
demandeurs d'asile ne fait qu'accroître
la gravité des soins pris en charge et
par ailleurs l'accès aux soins des
étrangers en situation régulière et de
plus en plus compliqué la mm est chers
collègues ce n'est pas un outil de la
politique migratoire c'est un outil de
santé publique et du reste les
tentatives de contrôle des montants par
cette approche de politique migratoire
sont voués à l'échec comme la constater
la commission des finances il serait
plus fructueux à tous égards de confier
le régime d'aide médicale d'État à
l'Assurance Maladie pour le coup pour
ces raisons si les crédits de la me
étaient maintenus et que s'instaurait un
dialogue fructueux sur ses amendements
nous pourrions voter les crédits de
cette mission la suite nous le dira ce
qu'il en sera je vous remercie merci la
parole est à Madame Laurence Cohen pour
le groupe communiste républicain citoyen
et écologiste pour 4 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues les liens
intrinsèques entre la mission santé le
budget de la Sécurité sociale se
retrouve au sein du nouveau programme
379 simple canal budgétaire qui prévoit
le financement par l'Union européenne
des dépenses d'investissement dans les
établissements de santé médicaux-sociaux
suite à la pandémie du covid 19 et qui
constitue l'essentiel des crédits de
cette mission concernant le programme de
104 consacré à la prévention la sécurité
sanitaire et l'offre de soins qui vise à
améliorer l'état de santé général de la
population dans un souci de réduction
des inégalités des inégalités nous
regrettons que le budget ne progresse
que de
1,6%. car comme le souligne Cyril
Delpierre directeur de recherche à
l'unisserm je cite en France on
considère qu'il y a 13 ans d'écart entre
l'espérance de vie des 5% les plus
riches et celles des 5% les plus pauvres
le PLF 2023 prévoit une baisse de crédit
pour le pilotage de la politique de
santé publique de 3,05% et aucune
évolution des crédits pour la réduction
des inégalités de santé comment
prétendre y parvenir avec en réalité des
moyens en diminution contenu notamment
de l'inflation nous avions espéré que le
changement d'intitulé du ministère de la
Santé désormais ministère de la Santé de
la prévention s'accompagne d'une
politique ambitieuse en matière de
prévention mais ce ne sont pas les 216
millions d'euros en 2023 qui permettront
d'agir véritablement pour réduire les
inégalités sociales territoriales
environnementales de santé concernant
les crédits du programme 183 sur la
protection maladie je veux rappeler ici
notre proposition de loi déposées au
mois de juin 2022 qui vise à intégrer le
budget de l'aide médicale d'État dans le
budget de la Sécurité sociale plus
exactement de réintégrer les personnes
étrangères dans le régime général de la
Sécurité sociale comme cela a été le cas
avant la loi Pasqua du 24 août 1993
avec la logique universaliste de la
sécurité sociale en subordonnant le
droit à l'assurance maladie des
étrangers à la régularité de leur séjour
la fusion de la me dans le régime
général de la Sécurité sociale est
demandée par les associations de
l'Observatoire du droit à la santé des
étrangers mais également par le Conseil
économique et social le Conseil national
du sida le Conseil national de politique
de lutte contre la pauvreté et
l'exclusion le Haut Conseil à l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes et même
l'inspection générale des finances et
des affaires sociales nous regrettons
que chaque année la droite fasse la
courte échelle à l'extrême droite à
l'occasion du débat sur l'ame pour
réduire les dépenses des étrangers qui
ne représentent pourtant que 0,5% des
dépenses de santé les deux amendements
du rapporteur clinger illus
malheureusement cette volonté la santé
est un bien commun mondial et
aujourd'hui les associations subissent
déjà les réformes de l'AM qui ont réduit
l'accès aux prestations et
considérablement complexifier les
procédure enfin je souhaite dénoncer ici
l'attitude du groupe Sanofi qui refuse
de financer l'indemnisation des victimes
de la dépakine en épuisant l'ensemble
des voies de recours juridictionnelles
pour contester sa responsabilité Sanofi
au 15e d'importants frais de justice qui
endettent l'Office national
d'indemnisation des accidents médicaux
ce qui est parfaitement scandaleux le
gouvernement doit à minima suspendre le
versement du crédit impôt recherche à
titre préventif pour contraindre Sanofi
d'assumer sa responsabilité auprès de
l'ensemble des victimes en conclusion
les sénatrices et sénateurs du groupe
CRCE voteront contre les crédits de la
mission santé qui demeure cette année
encore largement insuffisant je vous
remercie merci la parole est à madame
Jocelyne guidez pour le groupe Union
centriste pour 6 minutes chers collègues
madame la Présidente Monsieur Madame la
Ministre madame la rapporteur mes chers
collègues quand nous sommes jeunes nous
dépensons notre santé pour se faire une
fortune et quand nous sommes vieux nous
dépensons notre fortune pour se faire
une santé je tiens à remercier notre
collègue rapporteur madame Annie Delmont
encore au police pour la qualité de son
avis qui éclaire avec précision les
crédits de la mission santé dans le PLF
pour 2023 je ne puis que confirmer les
résultats de son analyse la trajectoire
des crédits de la mission santé est en
hausse sur 2023 2025 en 2023 les crédits
de la mission passeront de 1,3 à 3,36
milliards d'euros principalement en
raison de la création d'un nouveau
programme 379 doté de 1,93 milliards
d'euros ce programme permet de reverser
à la sécurité sociale les crédits
européens perçus dans le cadre du plan
de résilience au titre de financement
des dépenses d'investissement dans les
établissements de santé et
médico-sociaux ces crédits sont destinés
à couvrir les coudes et donc de vaccins
au pays étrangers à soutenir le volet
investissement Ségur du de relance
français ce programme spécifique
améliore la traçabilité du suivi des
fonds européens servant de simples canal
de transmission à l'assurance maladie il
ne redonne toutefois aucune substance
particulière à la mission en termes de
mise en œuvre d'une politique publique
le programme 183 porte 1,22 milliards
d'euros de dépenses d'aide médicale
d'État le nombre de bénéficiaires
continue d'augmenter le PLF 2023
garantit l'accès aux soins des étrangers
en situation irrégulière il nécessaire
de prévenir les risques de détournement
du dispositif et de renforcer et
développer des mesures de lutte contre
la fraude tout en favorisant l'accès aux
soins des plus vulnérables le régime de
l'Ame constitue une exception en Europe
la plupart des pays voisins ne prenant
en charge gratuitement pour les dangers
en situation irrégulière qu'un éventail
de soins comprenant les soins urgents
les soins liés à la maternité des soins
aux mineurs et des dispositifs de soins
préventifs dans des programmes
sanitaires publics nous soutenons
l'amendement de la commission des
finances rédigeant le montant de l'aide
médicale d'État pour tenir compte de sa
transformation en une aide médicale de
santé publique comparable à celle en
vigueur dans les principaux pays voisins
les sénateurs du groupe Union centriste
sont favorables également à l'amendement
de la commission des affaires sociales
portant sur la création d'un nouveau
programme consacré au financement
d'action conduites par l'État
l'assurance maladie et les associations
notamment dans le cadre de maraude
d'équipes mobiles de prévention ou
encore de barnum de dépistage ces
dispositifs sont destinés à proposer aux
personnes en situation irrégulière des
examens de dépistage et allaient
sensibiliser à la nécessité de
solliciter et de dispositif de l'aide
médicale de santé publique le programme
204 consacre 213 millions d'euros à la
prévention à la sécurité sanitaire et à
l'offre de soins mais de contribue plus
qu'au financement de deux agences
sanitaires l'Institut l'Institut
national du cancer et l'Agence nationale
de sécurité sanitaire de alimentation de
l'environnement et du travail des moyens
supplémentaires sont prévus pour
financer des systèmes d'information
notamment les outils numériques pérennes
pour améliorer la veille et
l'anticipation des situations de crise
il s'agit notamment de financer le
lancement de certains chantiers tel
l'entrepôt national de données de
biologie médicale la politique de santé
bénéficie en 2023 du news des
financements pour soutenir plusieurs
actions de prévention dont le plan de
déconne le plan national santé
environnement la stratégie nationale de
l'alimentation de la nutrition et du
climat la santé sexuelle la prévention
des addictions toutefois ces actions
hétérogènes et extrêmement dispersées
présentent un impact limité sur la
réalisation des objectifs de santé
publique poursuivi en matière de
prévention je souhaiterais aborder deux
points détection précoce des cancers et
dégradations de la santé des
Hospitaliers d'abord je souligne
l'importance de l'information au sujet
du cancer de la prostate qui entraîne
des décès pour être évité avec plus de
000 nouveaux cas par an en France se
cancer de plus fréquent chez l'homme le
dépistage anticipé permet une diminution
de 41% du risque de cancer métastatique
évitant ainsi l'aggravation de la
maladie et les chimiothérapies
traumatisantes il est essentiel de
renforcer des campagnes d'information et
des mesures de sensibilisation en ce qui
concerne le dépistage du cancer du sein
au cours de l'année 2021 2,7 millions de
femmes ont effectué le mammographie de
dépistage organisés ce qui correspond à
un taux national de participation de
50,6%. ce n'est pas suffisant ensuite la
réalité de la santé des Hospitaliers
nous inquiète vivement chers collègues
l'hôpital a tenu est une phrase que l'on
entend souvent si l'hôpital tient c'est
bien grâce aux Hospitaliers or ceci
apparaissent à bout de souffle une étude
menée par la MNH en partenariat avec la
chair santé de Sciences Po mais en
exergue un état de santé physique et
mentale dégradé notamment par rapport au
reste la population pour les
Hospitaliers d’exercices professionnels
constituent une source de
détériorisation de leur état de santé il
devient urgent de prendre soin des
femmes et des hommes qui prennent soin
de nous puisque prendre soin de sa santé
ne change pas l'issue mais le trajet
pour reprendre les mots de yaminsky il
nécessaire de déceler les axes
prioritaires potentiellement efficaces
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
la libération du temps consacré aux
démarches administratives le soulagement
des professions en tension autant de
leviers pour réduire la souffrance forte
continue mais désormais profonde qui
atteint les Hospitaliers la mission
santé vise en principe à développer la
stratégie de prévention assurer la
sécurité sanitaire et organiser une
offre de soins de qualité dans tous les
territoires et ces natures du groupe
Union centrices regrette néanmoins le
caractère inadapté de cette mission aux
objectifs et aux enjeux sanitaires ce
qui rend difficile tout évaluation en
conséquence le Gouvernement doit entamer
une réflexion pour élaborer une vision
stratégique à long il est temps
d'organiser l'action et de la financer
autour d'une politique sanitaire fondée
sur la prévention
la parole à Madame Catherine belerie
pour le groupe les républicains pour 5
minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers
la dotation du PLF 2023 pour la mission
santé connaît une croissance de près de
159% par rapport à 2022 qui s'explique
par le coût de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire et il faut le souligner à
important investissement en santé pour
les six prochaines années hors de ce
dernier programme donc qui n'est qu'un
simple canal budgétaire les crédit de
paiement de la mission connaissent une
hausse de 11% par rapport à la loi de
finances initiale de 2022 le programme
de prévention et de sécurité sanitaire
ne connaît pas d'évolution majeure et il
faut souligner que le fond de concours
initialement créé pour prendre en charge
des dépenses liées à la crise sanitaire
devrait s'éteindre à la fin de cette
année la hausse de la mission santé est
donc particulièrement soutenue par celle
des crédits de l'aide médicale de l'état
qui est de 13% par rapport à 2022 il
faut aller au fond des choses à ce sujet
et les évoquer avec clarté
ces dépenses sont essentiellement liées
à la mue de droit commun cette dernière
bénéficie aux étrangers en situation
irrégulière résidant en France de
manière ininterrompue depuis plus de
trois mois et dont les ressources ne
dépassent pas un certain plafond
lame de droit commun prévoit dès lors
une prise en charge intégrale des soins
médicaux et hospitaliers sans avance de
frais dans les limites des tarifs de la
sécurisation sociale or les chiffres de
la me blessent il baisse d'abord le
budget de l'État puisque la me ne
représentait que 139 millions d'euros
lors de sa création en 1999 elle est
ensuite passée de 772 millions en 2016 à
plus d'un milliard en 2023 et pour cause
le système français d'accès aux soins
des étrangers en situation irrégulière
est l'un des plus généreux de l'Union
européenne
qu'en déduire sinon que cette dépense
est devenue incontrôlable non maîtrisé
comme l'entrée justement dit comme la
très justement dit pardon ma collègue
Annie Delmont corrobulos ces chiffres
blessent plus encore l'acceptabilité
sociale du budget de l'État les débats
sociétés directement corrélés à celui
budget relatif à l'accueil à la gestion
des personnes étrangères en situation
irrégulière se répètent pourtant et plus
encore que les dispositifs législatifs
c'est l'efficacité exécutive qui
interroge à cet égard il ne s'agit pas
ici de faire resurgir d'autres sujets
mais simplement de les rappeler les
chiffres le nombre de bénéficiaires de
l'AME de droit commun était de 150 000
en 2002 il est désormais de 400 000 près
de 80% d'entre eux sont présents sur le
sol français depuis plus de 3 ans
une situation irrégulière peut-elle être
à durée indéterminée
et le rapport fait par notre collègue
Christian Klinger de conclure avec une
clarté adamantine que ce nombre ne fera
qu'augmenter à un rythme quasi
exponentiel si aucune réforme n'est
entreprise
comment faire supporter à nos
concitoyens les conséquences aveugles
d'une articulation
erratique entre politique publique et
d'une réforme de la mue jusqu'à présent
repoussée c'est constat force l'adoption
de réforme urgente car comme les
rapporteurs précités l'ont rappelé les
effets de mesura adoptés jusqu'à présent
n'ont été qu'un certain en matière de
régulation des dépenses et insuffisante
en matière de lutte contre la fraude les
rapports des commissions l'ont préconisé
il est d'abord nécessaire de recentrer
la hameuse sur les soins urgents comme
le font les autres pays d'Europe il
apparaît ensuite nécessaire d'exclure du
panier de soins certains gestes médicaux
et certains traitements de maladies non
graves dans le prolongement des
amendements déposés cette année
l'amendement proposé par la Commission
des finances à ce sujet revient une
importance décisive dont il faut
remercier nos collègues et qu'il faut
soutenir l'aide médicale d'État ce
compte désormais en milliards l'État
doit cesser de se comporter en payeur
aveugle je vous remercie merci
alors je vais suspendre la séance elle
sera reprise à 21h35 pour la suite de
l'examen de la mission santé la séance
est suspendue
[Musique]